joined i by the shadow of foreign
secretary david lammy hello to mr lambie
thank you for joining us on the
programme um
he was working really hard
uh it was the middle of a global
pandemic he took 10 minutes out what's
wrong with that
okay
the rules are clear that you couldn't
have a party
of more than two people a social
gathering of more than two people
indoors
what we know is that 30 people gathered
that his wife was there
and that the interior designer was there
as well
um if it was my birthday
and my wife
and an interior designer rocked up at
work
uh there was christmas cake birthday
cake and a celebration
it breaches the rules and the serious
side of this is that
at this time
the queen wasn't having a birthday party
boris had tweeted
just a few weeks earlier
a young seven-year-old girl who didn't
have her birthday party i remember my
own children not having birthday parties
we made a big cake for them we'd tweet
out and then people would say happy
birthday because they knew they couldn't
have a party
why was there one rule
for young people across the country who
couldn't have birthday parties for our
own queen and sovereign who couldn't
have a birthday party but a different
situation for boris johnson it's the
same drip drip drip and it's happening
at a time when people are dealing with a
cost of living crisis
energy prices
inflation
and we've got this serious problem in
ukraine what is going on why is he still
in office this was earlier on in the day
he was given a cake at a school but when
he went back to dining street it was the
cabinet room so it was a place of work
and the chancellor was there as well so
it it was a work meeting
look
the semantics of this is just so it's
unbearable
it's unbearable
people were putting up with sacrifices
number 10 should have been all about
work
in fact
um
you know most of westminster was very
quiet because many people were working
from home there were no other parties in
the whole of the palace of westminster
there weren't parties here
in sky or any of the other television
broadcasters it just wasn't done people
were taking the rules very very
seriously indeed except in number 10
downing street
that's what happened and i've got to
tell you we have a tradition in our
country
um
that
an englishman's word is his bond
we've had former prime ministers leave
office when they've got it wrong
chamberlain went left office when he
couldn't
unite the country with the unity
government winston churchill left office
when he felt he was too old and frail
theresa may left office when
she
messed up the general election david
cameron left office because he messed up
the referendum and we still have boris
johnson in office despite
imposing very tough restrictions on most
of the country
laws that he put in place that we all
had to live by
and yet we hear week after week after
week in these very serious times that
there were breaches in his number 10 and
he doesn't have to meet those rules it's
totally unacceptable either an
englishman's word is worth his bond or
not but he was i think he was born in
malta actually wasn't he or somewhere
anyway by the way um
he he set up sugray uh and the
investigation surely we have to wait for
that look he should have gone weeks ago
it frankly what is sue gray
investigating it's it's clear that there
were breaches of the rule let's let's go
back on this as well sue
okay first off first off he said first i
would have quite enjoyed investigation
first off he said
there were no parties
um
um there was no breach of the rules
then he said oh i'm furious that there
were parties um and um
allegra stratton
resigned
sean bailey i think
the conservative contender he also
resigned from his role in the greater
london assembly
then he moved on to
um i'm sorry that there were parties and
i apologize
um
but i didn't realize that i was walking
into a party uh and no one told me what
the rules were rules that he
made
this just goes on and on it's unbearable
it's unbearable who was in the cabinet
room um face a fixed penalty notice
what i can tell you is that at that time
i had constituents
who breached those very same rules
and they were subject
to uh criminal investigation and
sometimes criminal prosecution i had a
business shut down because it breached
the rules i had parties shut down by the
police because they breached the rules
and young people brought through the
courts
again why are there rules for my
constituents but not for boris johnson
is that a yes absolutely does that
include the chancellor look
we cannot have a country
in which any of us and that includes me
is above the law
but in this circumstance the prime
minister should simply resign step aside
and go and let someone else get on with
the job of running this very serious
country at this very very serious time
did he mislead parliament
he clearly misled
parliament he clearly missed that
parliament
it looks like on more than one occasion
and what do the rules say if you mislead
parliament you should go
it's a very serious business
to mislead your colleagues
and
even if it's unintentional
uh as i say at first he said that there
were no parties and there are there were
parties
so that was misleading parliament then
he said he didn't attend any parties and
it's clear that he did attend parties so
it's clear that he misled parliament uh
we don't have much time left but i do
want to ask you what's happening as far
as ukraine is concerned i did put it to
the transport secretary and he's
basically said watching brief at the
moment
we've heard from the united states that
they've got eight and a half thousand
troops on standby what should we be
doing either as uk troops or in the
guise of nato
well when i was in kiev a few weeks ago
what was clear is that they want the
full diplomatic support of the uk and
economic support and we stand with them
with that support we've got
800 troops in estonia at the moment
and of course the ukrainians
were talking about arms and how they can
support themselves in the event of an
invasion it was right the eu yesterday
provide them with economic support
and there may be more that we can do in
that regard in the coming days these are
very very serious times it's hugely
important that we stand
with our ukrainian allies
and very important for those
countries within nato that border
ukraine and russia that are very very
worried because what this represents is
a sort of expansionist
poutine sure but doesn't reflect the
sovereignty of countries around him what
do you think of the rhetoric though from
the ukrainian ambassador to the uk who
was sat just there a couple of weeks ago
talking about being on the edge of the
third world war i mean that that sort of
rhetoric doesn't help
look i i think that we have seen
expansionist ideals in europe before
um
and it's important to understand that
at the collapse of the soviet union
and the berlin wall that
ukraine gave up its nuclear weapons
and it gave up those nuclear weapons in
return for its independence its
sovereignty and the support of its
neighbours
and vladimir putin is breaching that
with that incursion
on the eastern side of ukraine
the annexing of crimea and now with
amassing troops along the borders of the
country he is breaching that and it's
important that the
western allies respond to that with
strength and are absolutely clear there
will be severe consequences but words
have consequences and we need to be
careful with the rhetoric
we want to dial down the rhetoric we
want the escalation
but in the end
dialogue must continue that
de-escalation must be
puting stepping back from what appears
to be
an escalation of troops because it is
his intention to invade that country or
else what
well
we've said that there would be very
severe sanctions
sanctions would damage the russians
economic sanctions would damage the
russian economy greatly
growth in russia last year was 0.3
percent it was 2.3 globally so
russia has already been hurt by
sanctions this would go much further
cutting russia out of the swift economic
system
uh
causing the real problem
where you can move the bankruptcy where
you can move money around
their currency the ruble has already
fallen uh overnight it will fall further
um and there are things that they
require like semiconductors that could
be we could impose sanctions as well so
uh all of that would cause damage to
them but yes gas that we have and our
fuel bills are ready astronomical
absolutely no one no one doubts that
sanctions don't hurt those imposing them
as well but you impose them because you
believe that it's a price worth paying
and it must be the case that the
democracy and sovereignty of the
ukrainians
is worth us giving them that support mr
lambie we must leave it there thank you
so much for joining us on the programme
this morning thank you